RACHEL AMARA: Hi everyone.
Welcome to our Artists
at Google today.
My name is Rachel Amara.
And I am really excited today to
host and introduce Freddie
Ravel to everyone.
So my story with Freddie is I
met Freddie a few months ago.
And he told me about his vision
for helping others
discover how music relates to
our everyday lives, how it can
help us to tune in--
no pun intended--
to live better lives through his
Tune Up concert, which is
what we're going to
experience today.
So after that, I knew I had
to bring him to Google.
Freddie was utterly captivated
by music since age five.
Freddie has recorded and
performed across six
continents with luminaries you
may know or heard of like
Madonna, Prince, the Boston
Pops, Earth, Wind, and Fire,
Carlos Santana, and
many others.
He's scored numerous Grammys as
well as the coveted number
one spot in US charts.
In response to the
ever-increasing challenges to
effective communication in the
workplace, Freddie created
Tune Up to Success, a unique
peak performance methodology
based on the universal language
of music that we all
know and love.
Dubbed the "Motivational
Maestro" by the city of Los
Angeles, he continues to garner
acclaim for clients
such as Google, Apple,
Citi, and NASA.
Today Freddie will share with
us his musical tools for
creating success in
our personal and
professional pursuits.
So please put your hands
together and help me welcome
Freddie Ravel.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FREDDIE RAVEL: Put your hands
together, everybody!
Good afternoon, Google!
All right!
Here we go!
[APPLAUSE]
FREDDIE RAVEL: Thank
you very much.
[SAYS "THANK YOU" IN MULTIPLE
FOREIGN LANGUAGES]
I say "thank you," ladies and
gentlemen, in all these
languages, because we live
in a world of global
opportunities and challenges.
Especially in this new digital
universe that we find
ourselves in.
It's racing before us, where
multiple cutting-edge
technologies are unfolding as
I say these very words--
especially in this building.
And I've got a few questions.
Is something as fundamental as
email a fabulous thing, or
this massive thing that eats
away, it saps away of our
time, the most commodity
that we have?
Is something like harnessing the
power of Google Hangouts,
LinkedIn, Facebook, Twitter,
texting-- to enhance our
personal and professional
relationships--
is there a better
tool to do that?
And finally, how do we access
the power and potential of our
world's greatest asset,
the people?
The people that we work with,
the people that we play with,
our clients, and
our colleagues.
With all this endless data,
what's the next tool that
could help us connect the
information to the people that
need to use it?
Today I am delighted to show you
how the structure of music
is really the structure of
success, and how it provides a
roadmap for all our pursuits,
personally and professionally.
How?
Well the structure of music is
the structure of success.
Now some of you might be
thinking, how could my
favorite song have anything
to do with success?
Well let's take a look.
Every fantastic piece of music
begins and is built on four
foundations of music.
The first foundation
is melody.
Throughout the ages, we find
that music that soothes the
soul and survives the centuries
always features a
strong melody.
Melody is then supported
by harmony.
Harmony provides the backdrop
that makes the
melody stand out.
And then after you have melody
and harmony, you need the
power of rhythm to drive melody
and harmony forward,
hence we have rhythm.
When melody, harmony, and rhythm
all come together, they
result in what we call
in music the score.
The score is the totality of
melody, harmony, and rhythm
coming together.
Now let's flip over and look
at any business, all right?
At the beginning of a business,
the very first thing
that launches all business
is leadership--
the leader.
Leadership needs the
power of teamwork.
After teamwork, you need to be
able to manage this across the
power of time.
So the management
of time is the
rhythm that drives business.
Finally when leadership,
teamwork, and time all come
together, you arrive at
the score of success.
So the structure of music is
the structure of success.
And there's a very organic
reason for
this, ladies and gentlemen.
You see, music is with us from
the cradle to the grave.
I mean you know, we all
enter the world.
And the first thing
we hear, you know?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FREDDIE RAVEL: And then you
know, a few years go by.
We're at about four,
five years old.
And it starts to get a little
more sophisticated.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FREDDIE RAVEL: Right?
(SINGING) Down came the rain--
Right?
And then after we get past
little "Itsy Bitsy Spider,"
you know, we get into
adolescence, right?
Adolescence--
the music begins to shift
a little bit.
It's more along the lines of--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FREDDIE RAVEL: Oh!
Dude!
Right?
And then as we progress, we get
into our 20s, 30s, and we
start to actually consider
that maybe
true love is out there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FREDDIE RAVEL: Mr. Right,
Mrs. Right, right?
At least we hope.
And music's there, right?
And if that goes right, music's
standing right there,
ready to support us, right?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FREDDIE RAVEL: It's there.
And if that goes right,
we make the next move.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FREDDIE RAVEL: Years start to
go by, anniversary after
anniversary, right?
Quinceaneras, Bar
Mitzvahs, right?
The holidays, year by year.
And eventually, we get to that
place where you know, I can't
do much about this one.
It's going to happen.
The music's there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FREDDIE RAVEL: And the really
cool thing about music is that
it's even there for
the Resurrection.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FREDDIE RAVEL: Cradle to the
grave, music is with us from
the cradle to the grave.
And there's another very organic
reason for this.
We are hardwired for music.
If I say to you--
and don't be shy right
now, everybody.
I know you're eating your lunch,
but check this out.
If I say, (SINGING) dun, dun
dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun,
dun, you say--
AUDIENCE: [SINGING]
FREDDIE RAVEL: And that
concludes my talk today, and--
we are hardwired for music.
We inherently understand
the power of the way
music is put together.
Now music is the great
invitation for mankind to
transcend spoken word, to
enhance how we think and put
into sync so we hear what
is mostly not heard--
the ground, Mother Earth.
The holy grail of everything we
do in life revolves around
the power of listening.
Nothing can happen unless we are
as present as possible and
we become extraordinary
listeners.
This is what makes music such
an exceptional, unique, and
powerful tool.
Because music is one of the very
few things in life that
we willingly listen to.
In fact, we actually
seek it out.
Remember that saying, we were
given two ears but only one
mouth because God said
that listening was
twice as hard as talking?
Well he--
or she--
was right.
I had the great honor and
pleasure to speak over at
Honda Motors a couple
years ago.
And I spent some time with the
president, Mr. Tetsuo Iwamura.
He has the North American
division of Honda.
And he explained to me that
at Honda, the emphasis on
listening is so powerful, that
it's so critical to their
success, that "listen" is the
first word in their operating
principle at Honda Motors.
And the operating principle at
Honda Motors is "Listen, Ask,
and Speak Up."
Now listening takes practice.
It's a lot of hard work.
And there's reasons for this.
You know, we speak at about 150
words a minute, average
human being.
But our minds go at 600 to
1,000 words a minute.
So you say something to
somebody, and their minds have
raced way ahead of you onto
something entirely different
like where'd I put my car keys
or should I reply that email.
People's minds are
wandering right?
Can everyone relate
to this one?
You say something to somebody
and they're wandering.
Very common, right?
Now there's a reason for this.
There are basically two
types of listening.
The first kind of listening is
called passive listening.
Passive is to listen
without reacting.
The second one is active.
Active listening is to
listen for meaning.
Now I'd like to share with
you a little bit
about Dr. Peter Senge.
Dr. Peter Senge is at MIT.
He's been called the business
strategist of the century.
And Dr. Senge says that to
listen fully means to pay
close attention to what is being
said beneath the words.
You listen not only to the music
but also to the essence
of the person speaking.
So what turns passive
listening into active listening?
Three basic ideas.
The first one is you've got to
listen for meaning when you're
speaking with anybody and
listening to them.
And number two, you have to
listen for what is being said
beneath the words.
And then my favorite is you have
to listen for the space
between the notes.
And I've got a little
tune up tip.
Is it all right if I share with
you a little tune up tip?
Because here it comes.
The tune up tip goes
like this.
If you take the word
"listen"--
L-I-S-T-E-N--
it happens to be an anagram.
Just by rearranging the letters,
you simply get the
word "silent." I invite
you all to own this
one, use this one.
It will serve you well.
Now one of the masters of
employing the power of silence
and the space between the notes
was the great Count
Basie who we lost about
a decade ago.
Now Count Basie was considered
the master of swing.
But he was also a master of the
space between the notes.
In fact, he was so good at the
space between the notes that
he actually developed a riff on
the piano that was filled
with space between the notes.
It went like this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FREDDIE RAVEL: Audiences fell in
love with this idea so that
when his big band would play all
over the country, at the
very end of his songs when he
would play those three notes,
the entire audience-- and I'm
talking about tens of
thousands of people-- would say,
(SINGING) Count Basie.
Filled with space.
The audience was completely
pulled-in to
the power of this.
Now the other thing that Count
Basie did is when he would
play a piece of music,
he'd put a lot of
space in the notes.
If we take a song--
a classic American jazz piece
like Duke Ellington's "Satin
Doll," the song goes
like this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FREDDIE RAVEL: Very famous
jazz tune, right?
Most pianists--
many musicians--
will come to the piano, and
they'll be all about the
melody, they'll all be about how
many notes can I play and
kind of show off?
What am I going to do?
And they start playing--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FREDDIE RAVEL: Ugh!
Who wants to hear that?
That's a lot of notes, right?
Do we care?
No!
We don't care about that.
Because when people play too
many notes and when they speak
to one another and they have
so much to say, there is no
respect for the listener.
And Count Basie understood
that you have
to honor your listener.
And the space between the
notes invites that.
So what does Count Basie
do with this song?
Well he goes like this--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FREDDIE RAVEL: You can snap
your fingers if you want,
right here.
Give me a little Google
click, right here.
How's that?
The space between the notes is
as powerful as the notes
themselves.
It is the space between the
bars of a cage that
keep the tiger in.
You've got to have that space.
It's awesome.
It's powerful.
And it is the structure
of music as the
structure of success.
Now I have to tell you, I have
been truly blessed to discover
many of the tools I'm sharing
with you under the guidance of
some amazing people.
I kind of have to pinch
myself sometimes.
But for many years, I had the
privilege of touring and
recording with Carlos Santana,
Al Jarreau, Earth, Wind, and
Fire, Madonna, all these
different artists.
And I'm very thrilled
to be here.
Because it's a privilege to
share the tools that I've
learned from these people and
offer them to you as tools
that you can use.
One of these tools is the very
beginning of our first
foundation, melody.
Melody.
Melody is the unique signature
of virtually
every piece of music.
It shapes the identity.
If you ask anybody how
does that song go?
People don't go [SINGING].
That's the bass line
of the drums.
They sing the melody.
Because the melody is the
identity of the song.
This is what's critical.
Now in music, we call
the melody the hook,
the hook of the song.
In business, it's called
the vision.
And whether it comes from the
lead singer or the CEO of a
company, it represents the
strength, passion, and purpose
of the song or the vision.
And it makes both leaders stand
up and say I am, and
this is my vision.
Now our first foundation of
melody is that melody is the
expression of leadership.
It is the lead idea in music.
It's the lead idea
in business.
And leaders, like songs, come
in many different styles.
You know, some leaders
come in.
They walk into the room.
And it's big.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FREDDIE RAVEL: Big!
Everybody!
OK!
Big!
They come into the room New York
style, Big Apple style,
kind of Richard Branson style.
Bigger than life
kind of energy.
And then you've got executives
that are the opposite.
They're almost like
quiet power.
You know, the energy's
along these lines.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FREDDIE RAVEL: Kind of like
Warren Buffett, you know?
Quiet power, quiet power.
And then you've got leaders--
and this is a trait you will
see in all leaders-- is the
ability to focus.
They focus on what they believe
in to such a point
that if they're dialed in on one
note, irregardless of all
the distractions, all the
dissonance that comes up, they
stick to the knitting
of what they believe
in, along these lines.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FREDDIE RAVEL: Can I get
a collective Ole!
AUDIENCE: Ole!
FREDDIE RAVEL: No matter how
chaotic the situation is, the
leaders who focus on that
note irregardless of the
distractions can punch through
and get their message heard.
This is what makes leadership
so powerful.
Now life and business
are team sports.
And if you ask any leader,
they will tell you that
they're only as good as the
team that supports them.
And this brings us, ladies and
gentleman, to our second
foundation of tune up,
which is harmony.
Harmony.
Leaders spend a lot of time
listening to their own voices.
This is kind of where
leaders hang out.
They hang out on their melody.
Harmony is the other
side of the coin.
In harmony, we spend time really
listening to each other
and honoring the spirit
of collaboration.
Harmony is about listening to
one another, but even more,
harmony is collaboration
with purpose.
The idea of harmony is making
the shift from "I am" to "we
are." I am to we are.
It's almost like in the world
of music going from being a
solo musician to deciding you're
going to integrate
another member of the band.
You go from I am to we are.
You expand the band, right?
This is very important.
And one of the great tips that
I've enjoyed sharing over the
years is something I want to
share with Google right now.
It's called listen to the
question behind the statement.
Now what's really fun about this
one is that professors of
music theory often call the
balance in music as the
question and the answer.
And good musicians do this
as a matter of practice.
They know that music is
constructed this way.
For example, Johann Strauss
writes "The Blue
Danube." The question--
[SINGING]
The answer is--
don't be shy.
I'm going to try that again.
The question is--
[SINGING]
AUDIENCE: [SINGING]
FREDDIE RAVEL: Ah, gracias.
Now let's take this one--
Mozart, "Symphony in
G Minor." [SINGING]
AUDIENCE: [SINGING]
FREDDIE RAVEL: Thank you.
It's for the San Francisco
Giants.
[SINGING]
AUDIENCE: [SINGING]
FREDDIE RAVEL: There you go.
I heard the "buy me some peanuts
and crackerjack." I
heard that one.
How about this one,
the Beatles?
[SINGING]
The answer--
Big, Google.
[SINGING]
Nice and big!
OK, I'm going to have to get
the Google bus and take you
all on the road with me,
take you all out.
So this is the power of the
question behind the statement.
Because once you understand
that, you start to see that
music is the symmetry.
All successful music
has a center.
But what happens when you have
two different viewpoints,
people getting together--
possibly for the first time--
and they have two different
questions and
answers going on?
So let's say you've got--
be hypothetical here, let's say
you've got Jane and sales
and you've got John
in marketing.
And they both come in with
a lot of enthusiasm.
Jane says hey, I've
got an idea.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FREDDIE RAVEL: It sounds
good, right?
In of its own, it's a very
complete statement, it's full
of enthusiasm, feels
good, right?
John walks in and says, hey.
I've got an idea.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FREDDIE RAVEL: In of its own, it
sounds pretty cool, right?
If you put Jane and John
together and they try to work
it out, this is what
it sounds like.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FREDDIE RAVEL: Happens all
the time on planet Earth.
What is the fundamental
problem here?
Well, first of all, neither of
them are really listening to
one another.
Number two, they're not
acknowledging each other.
Because they're in two
completely different keys.
You put people together.
They think they've got
the right ideas.
But their keys are different.
What has to happen?
What is the solution?
Harmony.
Because the definition of
harmony in Tune Up is
collaboration with purpose.
Simply by acknowledging each
other, John comes to the
conclusion that he's only
a half-step off.
And instead of--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FREDDIE RAVEL: --he just needs
to step down a half step,
readjust his listening.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FREDDIE RAVEL: And all of a
sudden, we put John and Jane
together, we get--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FREDDIE RAVEL: There we go.
So there you have it.
John and Jane collaborating
with purpose.
And this is how we
get from harmony.
Again, the structure of music
is the structure of success.
We arrive at our third
foundation, rhythm.
You can snap along.
Oh yeah.
Rhythm, the beat, the timing,
the tempo, rhythm.
Now we're all going to stop on
beat four, because music that
has melody and harmony without
rhythm is left with no
direction whatsoever.
So we're stopping on four.
A one, two, a one two,
three, four.
Space.
Without rhythm, melody and
harmony drift off into space.
And as we talk about space, I
need to share a quick story
with you about NASA.
About four years ago, I spoke
at the Goddard Space Flight
Center where they launched
the Hubble telescope
in Greenbelt, Maryland.
Now this place has the highest
concentration of
PhD's in the room.
This is a very melody-heavy
crowd.
And you have the inventors, the
people that put together
the Hubble or the Curiosity or
the next missions that are in
front of us.
Well these very same
people have harmony
that supports them.
You have logistics and human
resources that are providing a
harmony to those
melody people.
But the third people that walk
in are the project managers.
The project managers walk in and
say look, I'm really glad
that you inventors, you
melody people are
having a great time.
I'm thrilled that you
harmony people are
supporting the melody.
But you know what?
If this isn't on my desk by 10
o'clock on Tuesday, that
proposal that I sent to you,
we're going to pull the
funding on the entire program.
Now the drummer has shown up.
Rhythm is in the room.
Rhythm is the reality check
of where time shows up.
And now we get to our third
foundation, rhythm.
Rhythm paces action
across time.
And time is money.
And money is time.
And time keeps ticking to
rhythm's bottom line.
And one of the biggest robbers
of time is email.
We know email's an
incredible tool.
We all use it.
There's about 300 billion emails
that are sent around
the world every 24-hours.
It comes out to about 2.8
million emails per second that
are sent around the world.
What if I told you that the
company that makes the chips
that most of us have in our
digital devices has a policy
where they ask--
and highly advise--
their employees to take email
out of their week, 20% of
their work week?
Anybody know who
the company is?
Let me give you little
musical clue.
The musical clue is this--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FREDDIE RAVEL: Yeah, Intel.
Intel has a no email
on Fridays rule.
because they realize that one
day out of the week, it's
imperative that they
have interface,
that there is no email.
That there's actually
a conversation.
And they found out that that
actually increases their
productivity by having
this policy.
People actually interface
with each other.
I might add that Deloitte
& Touche also has
followed this policy.
And many other companies are
jumping on, on the bandwagon.
And it's all about rhythm
and keeping
time at its most efficient.
The great Duke Ellington had a
piece of music that was all
about rhythm.
He wrote a melody that
goes like this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right?
He also write a harmony
that goes like this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FREDDIE RAVEL: All right.
So if I got my melody over here,
and I got my harmony
over here, we get
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FREDDIE RAVEL: What's
wrong, everybody?
No rhythm.
No rhythm whatsoever.
In fact, Duke Ellington gave
this song a title about the
consequences of what happens
when melody and harmony run
awry and there's no rhythm.
Can anyone tell me the name
of this song, anybody?
Go ahead, say it.
AUDIENCE: "It Don't Mean a Thing
(If It Ain't Got That
Swing)."
FREDDIE RAVEL: "It Don't Mean a
Thing (If it Ain't Got that
Swing)." Thank you.
It don't mean a thing if
we're not listening.
You can have empowered
individuals, leaders, who sing
a great melody.
You could have a fantastic
team supporting them.
But until they become in sync
with the game plan of time
management and their rhythm is
paced across time, it don't
mean a thing.
But when they come together and
march to the beat of the
same drummer, you get--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FREDDIE RAVEL: Don't mean a
thing, if it ain't go that
swing, do wop, do wop, do wop,
as Duke Ellington would say.
The structure of music is the
structure of success.
You can look at it from so many
different angles, but
it's always there.
We discussed the power
of listening.
Then we went to the
power of melody.
Then we went to the power of
collaboration with purpose, of
harmony, and discussed
the management
of time over rhythm.
This seems simple on
many levels, right?
But like everything in
life, there is a
villain that shows up.
It's called you know,
dissonance.
It's that moment where
I've got an idea.
And she's got an idea.
And then someone else
has an idea.
No one returns the call and no
one's responding to this one.
And they're about to
nix this idea.
And I'm really not sure.
And I'm kind of overwhelmed.
And why is this spam
happening.
And why did the system
go down.
And why isn't this working,
people screaming at me.
Dissonance!
A reality for every human
being on planet Earth.
But music has a very powerful
way of dealing with
dissonance.
Dissonance is actually conflict
and opportunity at
the same time.
And if we manage it the right
way, dissonance makes music
going from the bland
to the grand.
It takes something that's very
vanilla sounding and actually
makes it astounding.
And this is what happens.
Especially when we learn
to agree to disagree.
This is one of the key things.
And I want to share with you
a quick story about two
songwriters that you may be
familiar with, John Lennon and
Paul McCartney.
And John Lennon and Paul
McCartney statistically, over
the years, rank as the most
successful songwriting team in
the history of music.
Their music has been around
for 50 years now,
and it still is vital.
And one thing that made that
particular group exceptionally
dynamic is that they
agreed to disagree.
Paul McCartney wrote the
optimistic, sunny side of many
of the Beatles songs.
Whereas John Lennon would
write the more dark,
melancholy perspective
on the music.
So if we take a song, for
example, like "We Can Work It
Out," by the Beatles, right,
by John Lennon and Paul
McCartney, Paul comes in with
this very optimistic idea.
[SINGING]
Full of optimism.
We can work it out.
I mean the sun shining
when he sings this.
In the same song--
in the very same piece of
music-- and very few pieces of
music ever do this--
John Lennon comes in, not in a
major chord, he comes in on a
minor chord.
Not in the same rhythm
that Paul just said--
in a completely different
rhythm and a completely
different message.
He says [SINGING].
Completely different.
The Beatles understood this.
And this is why their music is
timeless in so many ways.
It continues to live on because
they understood how to
agree to disagree.
Conflict resolution
at its best.
So my friends here at Google,
I got to tell you, we don't
just carry music in an iPod.
We carry music in our hearts.
Food, water, shelter, music.
Music is a core survival tool.
The six-year-old kid in Rio de
Janeiro who picks up a gas can
and a stick and starts drumming
on that to relieve
the pangs of hunger he feels
in this stomach.
The college student who enrolls
in an after-school
music program and because of
that has a shot of increasing
her test scores by a national
average of 20% because she
studies music.
Or a Congresswoman by the name
of Gabby Giffords who
attributes her amazing
miraculous recovery from a
gunshot to the head to
the power of music.
We are dealing with the rocket
fuel for humanity.
This is what music truly is.
And we have landed on the fourth
foundation of music,
which is called the score.
Melody--
to help us express leadership.
Harmony to express collaboration
and teamwork.
Rhythm to pace us across time.
And the score where we achieve
our dreams of success.
The structure of music is the
structure of success.
And I want to thank my
friends at Google.
I want to thank the wonderful
[INAUDIBLE].
I want to thank Justin Oliver
and the wonderful Rachel Amara
for inviting me to be
here with you today.
It has been my pleasure
to speak with you.
And I want to end now with
something on the global level.
All right?
This is global.
And I thought we would mash up
a little bit of Mozart with
some mojitos.
That OK with you?
All right.
Next time I come up to Google,
we'll make sure that we are
serving mojitos as we're doing
this, but here it is.
And a little help from
Wolfgang Amadeus.
Here we go.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FREDDIE RAVEL: Thank
you very much.
RACHEL AMARA: Thanks
everybody.
And we have a few moments for
question and answering.
So does anyone have
any questions?
AUDIENCE: So you talked a lot
about what many people call
European music or the
music that came
out of European music.
Now there is a very different
kind of music that you see
mostly in Asia and there
are different kinds.
Chinese music is very different
from European music.
Japanese music is
very different.
And so are the business
practices.
So are the ways people work
with their managers, how
people are treated
in their work.
And even though it's very
different from what you're
describing--
for example, Japan is very
successful in what it achieves
in its companies.
Can you somehow comment
on that?
FREDDIE RAVEL: Absolutely.
Sure, thank you.
So one thing we need to say
about the power of melody as
you do it in Japan--
and I've had the privilege of
playing in Japan about 15
different times and spending
a lot of time there.
I've noticed in that particular
culture, you have
your lead instruments, right?
You have either the voice
or the [INAUDIBLE]
of the koto-- various
instruments
that take the lead.
And what we're doing is we're
taking the lead instruments of
any culture, whether it's
the [INAUDIBLE]
in Australia or it's
of Japan or the [INAUDIBLE]
of Japan.
And we're simply saying that
these lead instruments that
lead and spotlight in the music
can be looked at in much
the same way as leadership
is looked.
When you look at a bandleader
who spotlights those
instruments, they are leading
their organization.
So we're using the metaphor,
if you will,
of music as a parallel.
Indeed, in Japan you might
see like the [INAUDIBLE]
system, right?
Where people work on a
more like harmony.
Collaboration is very big in
Japanese culture, for example.
You might see an even greater
level of that.
There's a more uniformity
in that culture.
Whereas you might see a brasher
more outrageous
leadership style in places
in the West,
in America for example.
So they exist.
But these are some of the
different ways that we can
look at them and parallel
them to music.
Any other questions?
RACHEL AMARA: I have a
question I'll ask.
FREDDIE RAVEL: Sure.
RACHEL AMARA: So
that was great.
Thank you, Freddie.
And I'm wondering how a company
like Google can take
this info and have this apply
to what we do here.
So knowing all of us are on
different teams, we do
different things.
What can we take back to help
share the message and what
we've learned from this today?
FREDDIE RAVEL: Thank you.
Thank you, Rachel.
There are four particular points
that I've been driving
home through the talk.
The structure of music is the
structure of success.
And that melody is
a lead idea.
And harmony is a collaborative
idea.
And rhythm is an idea
about time.
And the score is the holistic
sum of that,
the sum of that total.
Sometimes when you can look
at something as complex as
teamwork or as complex as human
interfaces, right, and
drill it down to the way the
basic structure of music is,
it can be very beneficial.
For example you're working with
a team person and they
really are in a different key.
I mean they're in a completely
different key.
And it really sounds like
that example I gave you.
You may look at it and instead
of getting completely upset at
the dissonance that you're
having with that team member,
you might step back and
say wait a second.
That person's really coming
from almost a completely
different culture, a different
perspective.
They are in a different key.
So what can I do to
adapt to that key?
So this may be a message in this
context about adapting
and conforming, finding that
agree to disagree.
Because the only way we grow,
the only way any company
becomes successful, is you've
got to have those rubs.
You've got to have
those challenges.
What makes our team better is
that if someone comes in with
an idea is foreign and we all
get around it and wrap
ourselves around it and
make our effort to
adjust to that key--
in the long run, that can be the
idea that explodes, that
is the next big idea.
So this is the only way we get
to the next big idea is
through some dissonance.
That's the message there.
RACHEL AMARA: All right.
Well thank you, Freddie.
Thanks so much.
FREDDIE RAVEL: You're
very welcome.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]